el rey emérito juan carlos de 84 años
llegó a españa en avión privado poco
después de las 7 de la tarde a vigo en
el noroeste del país donde pasará el fin
de semana asistiendo a una competición
de veleros han pasado casi dos años
desde que pisó suelo español cuando en
agosto de 2020 se fue a vivir a emiratos
árabes unidos- huyendo de la presión de
la justicia que dos meses antes habría
un tercer caso en su contra por
irregularidades fiscales según el
emérito que abdicó en 2014 este cambio
de vivienda lo hizo para facilitarle la
tarea a su hijo el rey felipe sexto en
marzo de este año la fiscalía española
al archivo todos los casos en contra de
juan carlos de borbón pero no porque no
se hubieran encontrado indicios de
delito sino porque los hechos habían
prescrito o se cometieron mientras el
emérito gozaba de inmunidad como monarca
esto despejó el camino para su regreso
al territorio del que fue rey durante 39
años el lunes vendrá a madrid donde se
reunirá con el rey felipe sexto en el
palacio de la zarzuela residencia
oficial de la familia real ese mismo día
volverá de regreso a
ha sido una figura clave durante la
transición democrática en españa pero
que levanta mucha polémica mientras que
desde el partido socialista en el
gobierno que dé explicaciones la
vertiente más de izquierdas del gobierno
de coalición en la unión de unidas
podemos pide que rinda cuentas ante la
justicia y que se reabra el debate de la
inviolabilidad del monarca la derecha
por su parte aplaude el regreso de juan
carlos porque dicen es una persona libre
y como español puede regresar a su país
cuando quiera